Without going into too much explanation, I transferred some DMSO into a dropper model for easy application.
Once in a while, I get that model mixed up with my whole way of hathic drops,
and I put a few drops of the DMSO in my mouth by mistake.
Actually, I spit it out promptly since it tastes like liquid, you know what, must be the sulfur.
Just, but just how stupid or dangerous is this at a scale of 1 to 10?
Where what is, don't worry about it.
And 10 is that's perfectly fine to take orally, and then 10 is that you have to take measures
to ensure it never happens again, and you're lucky you didn't die.
There isn't really any harm in that at all.
The DMSO has the capability of absorbing very quickly.
That's why it has benefits to use it topically.
And the sulfur in it, because it's di-bethyl sulfoxide, what the sulfur does is works as an anti-inflammatory.
That's why, you know, initially when the DMSO was created, it was beneficial for like the inflammation
or, you know, pain in your hands and, you know, like an inflammatory pain due to,
like an inflammatory arthritis or something, and it can help bring down that pain.
The negative is that the positive is that it absorbs really quickly,
and it can help decrease that pain and by decreasing the inflammation.
The negative is that it absorbs really quickly, and it gets into your bloodstream really quickly.
And you, you know, the reason why I kind of kind of fell off the map of using it for inflammatory
processes is because people tended to overuse it because it worked well, but then that sulfur,
you get a lot of sulfur in your bloodstream, and you actually can taste it.
So you can taste that garlicky taste when you overuse the DMSO, and people didn't like that.
Can it have any dangerous effects on the body?
The only time it can have a dangerous effect when you have different defects that you,
you tend to not be able to process sulfur very well.
It's a few people, it's not very common, and those are the people that don't do well with eating garlic
or don't do well with eating onions because those are also sulfur compounds.
Most people are healthier eating onions and healthier, getting more sulfur in, but not everybody.
Some people don't get rid of that very well. But on a scale of 1 to 10 as far as danger,
and putting a few drops in your mouth, it would be a zero. It's not dangerous whatsoever.
You are getting it into your bloodstream when you put it on your skin because it's absorbing so
quickly. There's no danger. Of course, anything has some sort of lethal dose. If you took the whole
drop or a bottle of it, probably still wouldn't be opposed to anything like that. But it does taste
horrible, and that's one of my kind of fellow home of favorite using it, typically.
No one can have some great benefits. I mean, you've heard of using MSM, which is a supplement
that's a powder. It's not a liquid. And MSM supplements can be extremely beneficial for people
for inflammatory issues. But again, same thing. It's a sulfur based powder. If you take too much of
that, you can get rid of that garlic. It tastes good to take a lot of the MSM to get that. But
it's an anti-inflammatory. It's not going to hurt you. It's not going to hurt your mouth.